[Applaudissements]
on y va
patronne mon ch du plus loin que me
revienne l'ombre de mes amours anciennes
du plus loin du premier
rendez-vous du temps des premiers
repines l j'avais 15 ans à peine cœur
tout blanc et griffe au genou que ce
fugetta précoce de tendres amours de
gosses où les morsures d'un amour 'en
fou si depuis je dis je t'aime tu plus
loin que me
revienne la plus belle histoire d'amour
c'est
vous souple alors hein ah ben c'est très
gentil c'est très discret personne va
moi ce n'est
rien tu le sais bien le temps passe ce
n'est
rien ce n'est rien
elles s'en vont comme les bateaux et
soudeins
ça
revient pour un pateau qui s'en va et
revient il y a m000 coquill de noir sur
ton chemin qui coule et c'est très
[Musique]
bien c celle-là c'est une de mes préfér
je te
gu toi qui est femme de
président tu en as pas moins de cœur
pour autant de voir tomber des têtes à
la fin ça t'embête et ton mari le
président qui t'aime bien qui t'aime
tant quand tu as le cœur qui flanche
tripote la
balance j'ai j'ai la raison à raisonné
comme un grand désert teréritoir toute
ma vie s'est arrêtée comme s
l'histoire j'ai la raison
raisonner terrisoire toute ma vie s'est
arrêtée comme s'arrêterait l'histoire
[Musique]
elle fut longue la route mais je le fête
la route celle-là qui menait jusqu'à
vous et je ne suis pas
PARG si ce soir je vous jure que pour
vous je l'ai faite à genoux il en e
fallu bien d'autres que quelques mauvais
apôtres que l'hiver et la neige à mon
cou pour que je perde patience et j'ai
calmé ma
violence ma prire d'amour c'est
vous ma plus belle histoire
d'amour c'est
vous merci
beaucoup